two players towards topside a connector
and jungle respectively they've actually
row two back in toward shadow position
and soos that's gotten under there he
finds rain as a result of it play he's
following it up they're doing massive
damage simple and Sue's goodbyes to take
down Kerrigan they've got to recover
anikó has that if the men tremendous
demand for mechanics has invaded one of
the world bent knee go get absolutely
destroyed Zeus
it gets the arm of the only plan
invested anything is that it struck on
the ladder Vito the West great move and
fancy footwork from Zeus and it's enough
to pick up the rounds guys I've said it
before and I'll say it again
respect your [ __ ] elders and see us
go more than any other eSport age is
just a number obviously I have to say
that because I'm pretty [ __ ] old but
they do say that with age comes wisdom
and what's old is gold not gold Nova
that's why this week we're giving you
the best of csgo
old guys who can still kick ass now what
is old in csgo well for this video our
criteria was pretty malleable but we
decided to cut it off at 26 years and
older and only show highlights from the
last couple of years not from these
players pride now you might be saying to
yourself Colin 26 years old is a far cry
from a midlife crisis but just remember
when you're in the server with kids like
xilu and ROPS they're gonna make you
feel pretty old pretty fast great close
phrasing to get your Walker ready put
your dentures in and make sure you have
a glass of Metamucil at the ready here's
the very best of CS goes old guys
kicking ass
this round is so important for mouse
through banana rocks is able to find the
first shot and we're gonna come in with
the equalizer bananas jr. now it's kinda
[Music]
mortals now feeling like they know what
to do two challenges stood on a position
the gambit is sending to more firepower
bats
bring more cause it's huge Georgie stood
in the corner
get blamed on it's been all ni P in the
second half pissed around won by SK and
they haven't gotten a single round after
that get right Oh what is that reaction
yeah right get out fir res can't land
that gets taken down and jackin he's
hurt as well right let's try this thing
off quick on the bump side here and now
get right can you get the sneak in
almost making a bit of noise they hear
it coming he still wins the fight and
helps his teammates out three on three
now he's back into it they're trying to
see if they can make this one boy the
bomb is - but we at the moment again and
getting the kill on sniffing hiding
weeding hoping that they're gonna come
and all hit on the free such great
timing and he realized this probably the
device gonna try and switch it up he
doesn't want anything to do with that
shotgun it's hiding in the vent device
is gonna be there in time it looks like
he has the upper hand right now looking
for it get right does have a Molotov so
if device or he's gonna go for the pond
right in front trying to get up yeah he
wants the grenade what am I in game
trying it on summer device I can't
believe it no palm part and now kit
rights waiting on the other side he's
almost done this the triple need the
quad kill for the cocktail
[Applause]
ninjas in pyjamas is a historic roster
and it's anchored by a historic duo get
right is a legend who can still hang
with the best of them and likewise
Forest at 30 years old is an old lion
with some very sharp teeth it's four
versus two for norfair this is pretty
unbelievable it's not every day you see
those cravat turn around so there we go
Boris can still save today Oh Kenny ever
think plant though oh my goodness forest
that what our reaction is well to find
the fourth great hold from a strong it's
just a great job isn't it
thirty Seconds again for a 1vs1 way of
taking down 25 seconds once again he's
picked up the palm and he wants to go
upstairs making a bit of noise you can
choke them out and just be as noisy as
possible maybe they're gonna be looking
the wrong way but they're hiding in the
corner now it's not one-on-one makers
coming in he's just out of the bottom
forest he needs one more kill will be
historic but if he could do his bunny
landing on top he's down to 50
little 10 players still life bloodsheds
not been spilled just yet but now here
it comes to the flurry and it's gonna
mainly be the terrorists blood that
stains the ground of train meanwhile
blacken and forest they've got to try
and get some work done
no Molotov to use as a smoke on the site
anyway foresters picked up one can he go
any better than that
he isn't still very much it's gonna go
to alpha to get the immediate kill on
cold the important aspect for SK bomb
did go down ality just inside of it a
linear position trying to elevate
himself and catch them off and I think
Ally may just go for the stick on this
Volans gonna try and walk back in as
they both get close enough rain
considering up or has a Lugo look
that might be the game it's absolutely
brilliant play from fallen as he nails
bull shots it's on d'amico he's heard
felt was dropped back down but he's got
to try and fade out the time and felt
was one alive need gonna work with mom
she's down to ten and he goes to the
upper desperation ball
and simple this time gets the bomb down
is it enough - plans remain Zeus and
simple hold on to whatever they carry
three dots great read from Zeus to hold
off as well because he knew CG between
them so the vent was nest lifeless nests
likely I should say what a shelf of
Guardian words out of my mouth as he
nails it through the Box he is tagged up
smoke on the ball immediately he's got
the kid to hold on tight angle and it
works because micro on the second off
this time is able to catch Nico deep
inside of the sight the man who I
thought was gonna go for the contact way
is suddenly the last to live this is a
done round or door Graham I swear to God
if you ever talk [ __ ] about Guardian I
will find out where you live
I will come to your house and I will
give you a very stern talking-to because
this guy in contention for the greatest
opera of all time can still hang with
the best of all Guardian now is question
as to whether he'll save the AWP good
flashbang could get a couple more out of
this one I starting to crumble what's
going on one player has found three
kills Guardian look into Asus one now
this could be one of the best rounds of
the entire tournament so far four kills
picked up is down the crimped this was a
5 vs. 1 map and he's got time as well
the bomb won't be on his back and he's
going for the long con here the long con
he won't over commit to it he went back
thinking crumbs would reveal himself
he's just molotoved himself off the bomb
in one of the force out from barrel
scrims now knows he's inside of the
sniper guardian has every opportunity or
right to make this a remarkable 1vs5
Crim's will hear him heading toward air
but that means he won't get there in
time to deny the plant there's nothing
that can be done at least for that facet
he knows he wasn't in B so he's got to
be toward bathroom surely Guardian looks
that direction with it down in position
Crim's not looking yet Guardian just
behind the box
that also means Crim's will get closer
to the site by the stairs
[Applause]
we'll wait for this to go to time and
Cindy arey could be a factor because if
he puts it in front of Guardian
how does he work back in it's gone
toward the dumpster that means Guardian
knows exactly why there is the world's
best sniper comes alive in the fiber
versus one and now the folks decide
elsewhere in banana leaves fallen only
12 seconds to make a miracle occur they
may be able to get the bomb planted not
too bad all things considered - JW as
well that opens up the chance now
waiting gambling that both players come
from the same side and he is correct and
function down into a 4 V for now and
they are trying to push back in but
there's more pressure about to work its
way in from both sides of this one VP
but cloud 9 are also rotating back at an
8 just picked up to kill snacks
he's running wild but unfortunately just
lost his entire team neo though with the
flick shot on the shroud destroying him
unfortunately he's down to one HP and 1v
to anything yet one of these kills again
it really does hurt 5-3 by in the next
round the bleep is one aggressively you
may be facing a lot on 15 health is neo
gonna do it again you've got so many in
this kind of situation
right now just looking for a qualm plan
that would be great to get a bit of a
money bonus if you find even more stuff
in the net trunk Rene can I draw pain at
the feet oh my god Hacha
a nuclear bomb exploding dosha hobbit
what is the matter with Pasha what it
actually got stuck under his feet it was
a literal claymore mine
I love Pasha biceps
I love virtus Pro now admittedly the
plow roster did not have the most
successful twilight years but if you
caught him on a good day they would
still take you to school Paschal London
School of course papa I mean this is
psychological warfare isn't it
accidentally Bobbitt now he's in the
showers just like him Theresa Moses
you've gotta be careful where's the
knife at the quad kill with the knife if
you have pads with either repeat it
towards danger he's actually been tagged
so surely he's not long for this world
has actually gets one more killed Hodge
gets another elizalde done that it's
just gonna be Taz versus frozen time to
stop it what the AWP that is dirty VP
back on the fight I can't say this will
be a great one they've got an over UMP
well Neos about to meet his maker they
are out ramp he's found one that I think
that's good enough right you do want a
little bit more neo this early done his
job with three kills pistol is out
trying to catch the last one but he's
hidden in the smoke the criminal is he's
waiting to fire finally I want to get
right maybe upgrade he's gone he's done
exactly that drop before them good find
za k back but his entire team have made
up the round it doesn't matter neo 3
make that four kills of the nade
postmortem
well guys that's all she wrote for the
very best of old guys in csgo kicking
ass now of course we could not highlight
every geriatric player in this
particular video but we'd love to do a
part 2 and if you want to see that hit
the like button let us know in the
comments below and I'll see you next
week
hey Colin I know you're old and all but
what is what is Gucci mean lucci means
everything's good everything's alright
everything's going according to plan
as in full by yeah we Gucci let's get it
ass can it short for of course let us
get it let us acquire that risen use
that bread if you will eat youth is a
tough one because he also means like
this is good like this is sick it's just
like we're gonna dump to these guys eat
but it's also a verb you can eat on
someone right like oh what happened you
won't be to them yeah eat it on them
that's it nice
did I pass yeah I think I did I think
I'm young as [ __ ] how do you do fellow
kids what come on come on I can't be in
this office and not know those words
come on I got this